[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans point
de vue ravis de vous accueillir pour
notre rendez vous quotidien et pour une
fois on va pas parler de confinement
mais plutôt de déconfinement c'est une
perspective qui semble se rapprocher
plusieurs indicateurs semblent passer au
vert alors comment confiné qui doit
ouvrir ou rouvrir en premier nous allons
en parler nous allons aussi parler de ce
débat autour de l'enseignement de
l'arabe à l'école et c'est un bon moyen
de lutter contre le séparatisme ou au
contraire faut-il laisser l'éducation
nationale à l'écart de tout cela nous
allons en parler avec nous deux invités
bon soit gabriel cluzel vous êtes
rédactrice en chef du site boulevard
voltaire vous êtes également essayiste
et votre dernier livre enraciné nous
sommes tous d héritier a été publiée aux
éditions arte est j'éclaire chartier est
avec nous aussi bon soir claire vous
êtes la rédactrice en chef des pages
idées de l'express vous aussi vous êtes
et céistes votre livre le violet nous
enquête sur un fléau social a été publié
aux édition de l'observatoire et puis je
le disais vous êtes une des
collaboratrices est mignon de l'express
et alors cette semaine en couverture de
l'express
ah ça fait du bien l'espoir enfin c'est
évidemment une allusion au vaccin mais
peut-être peut-on élargir cet espoir aux
perspectives d'un déconfinement le
président de la république et le premier
ministre doivent s'exprimer sur ce sujet
la semaine prochaine les indicateurs
sanitaires sont plutôt bons alors est-ce
qu'on voit le bout du tunnel
il va falloir être prudent a écouté
c'était il ya quelques minutes à la
sortie du conseil des ministres
gabriella talent le porte parole du
gouvernement et est d'une prudence de
sioux peut-être effectivement que nous
et voilà alors on a vu le brouillard ce
qui est discuté en ce moment réfléchi
travaillé qu'ils pourraient être
annoncés le cas échéant une adaptation
du confinement à partir du 1er décembre
ont des joueurs qui l'entourent mais
nous ne sommes pas du tout aux
déconfinement on est même loin on parle
d'une adaptation éventuelle du
confinement à partir du 1er décembre si
la situation sanitaire
voilà si la situation sanitaire le
permet face à cette prudence il y à
l'exaspération la colère aussi d'un
certain nombre de professions notamment
les commerçants indépendants
écoutez ce témoignage il est bref mais
fort c'est celui d'anne de l'aigle c'est
une des porte-parole du collectif au nom
des indépendants à lyon à quel moment on
peut être sacrifié sur l'autel de la
crise sanitaire c'est à dire que
effectivement on à protéger les plus
faibles pour la crise sanitaire ce qui
est normal et aujourd'hui pour la crise
économique on laisse les plus gros s'en
sortir ils s'en sortiront très bien
c'est à dire que eux n'ont pas de
problème et nous on va crever parce que
trouver c'est le mot c'est exactement ce
qu'il nous aide c'est pas normal c'est
injuste on puisse tellement injuste à
chartier le le les céistes maxime
tandonnet design figaro hier la colère
est en train de prendre le pas sur la
peur et donc il ya urgence à desserrer
l'étreinte est-ce que c'est aussi votre
point de vue je pense qu'il a raison ça
c'est ce qu'on sent monter la difficulté
de ce sujet c'est que l'économie ne peut
pas aller bien
si on n'arrive pas à bout de cette
pandémie donc ça c'est le cadre général
malheureusement c'est celle comment dire
c'est vraiment le facteur numéro un dont
il faut tenir compte et c'est ce que
sept gouvernements ensuite à l'intérieur
il ya effectivement des arbitrages amené
dans un climat de tension qui qui était
en train de victimes en prendre je pense
qu'on n'est pas loin d'atteindre le
seuil d'acceptation maximale de la
contrainte alors est ce que il faut
s'attendre une explosion sociale comme
certains
l'evoke ces derniers temps c'est pas
impossible surtout que en écoutant votre
intervenantes
on sent très bien que se greffe sur le
co vide se rejoue en quelque sorte le
jeu de la justice sociale de cette de
cette musique et de ce refrain qu'on
entend qu'on a entendu avec les gilet
jaune et donc là il ya un risque
politique
c'est extrêmement inflammable et c'est
évident et il ya un autre risque
politique qui a été déclenchée par ces
mesures c'est le défi à l'autorité comme
on l'a vu avec les maires qui sont allés
jusqu'à quand même enfin inciter leurs
commerçants à braver les mesures c'est
quand même pas rien pour un gouvernement
que de devoir affronter cette donne là
donc tout ça une boutabout il faut
encore ajouter en plus une crise quand
même particulière qui salue terrorisme
donc on a en france le co vide on a eu
les gilet jaune et maintenant on a en
plus le terrorisme qui est repartie très
fortement
je pense que là en effet le gouvernement
est obligé va être obligé de lâcher du
lest je ne vois pas comment il va
pouvoir faire autrement on a vu quelques
instants le premier ministre apparaître
à l'écran
imaginez que vous preniez sa place
demain matin on vous appelle à matignon
qu'est ce que vous feriez qu'est-ce que
vous réouvrir y ait en premier parmi
tous les commerces les lieux de culte
les salles de sport tout ce qui a été
arrêté avec le nouveau confinement
scania je ne suis pas premier ministre
mais je je vois en effet qu'il ya trois
soucis principaux me semble-t-il etc
cela de cela dont je parlerai au premier
ministre si j'avais l'occasion de le
faire comme vous le dites
le premier c'est la durée on voit bien
que ce genre de musique
extrêmement sévère ne peut pas durer et
lui on a besoin qu'il est rentré dans
une optique on a entendu parler ça a été
beaucoup commentée de dante et
confinement c'est devenu la nouvelle ère
avant on disait avant jésus-christ
maintenant dix ans tu es confinement
donc il n'y a même pas de notion de
retour à la normale donc ça a quelque
chose d'un petit peu stressant or on
sent bien que sur la durée
il ya une perte de liberté qui est quand
même insupportable dans un état de droit
c'est évident il ya la notion de
d'absolutisme biologique c'est à dire
que on considère qu' il n'y a plus que
la biologie c'est à dire comme des
animaux d'ailleurs la l'aligorie c'était
assez symbolique la sphère de la bride
donc on a beaucoup commenté aussi du
premier ministre démontre que nous
sommes est relégué à une autre nature
animale je rappelle louis desserré la
bride et non ce n'est pas le moment de
desserrer la marge est pas le moment de
l abri seriez pas le moment de desserrer
la pression un petit peu des bourricots
du thé ou des poneys donc et donc
l'animal il survit is nourris et le exit
la vie culturelle religieuse enfin
spirituel la vie familiale la vie
sociale donc tout cela c'est ça devient
extrêmement insupportable il faut
renouer avec et dernier point c'est que
il ya une notion d'arbitraire c'est à
dire qu'ils étaient moins sensiblement
du premier confinement ce compromis - du
premier continent tout le monde peu ou
prou était tout le monde était logé à la
même enseigne avait un sentiment de peur
parce qu'on savait pas très bien qu'on
allait la même si le virus est sérieux
il a peuplé rétabli que ce n'est ni
ebola ni la peste noire ni le choléra je
vous renvoie au hasard sur le toit on
n'est pas dans les mêmes conditions
donc les on est dans l'arbitraire parce
que c'est le gouvernement qui décide ce
qui est essentiel et ce qui ne l'est pas
à conditions sanitaires égale donc pour
répondre enfin votre question tout cela
étant établie il est évident qu'il faut
où il faut ouvrir ces petits commerces
parce que sinon évidemment il me
les gens qui les tient à une mourrons
mais également les personnes qui les
fréquentent je pense à toutes les
personnes âgées dans les petites villes
ses deux soeurs celle du lien social
donc on voit que l'aspect économique
mais aussi sociale et puis il faut
évidemment rouvrir les lieux de culte on
voit que la liberté et que la gronde à
nîmes un certain nombre de gens comme on
est là on l'a vu sur les parvis ce
week-end et c'est essentiel ne serait ce
que parce que souvent la liberté de
culte elle est un bon indicateur des
libertés en général quand on s'intéresse
un peu à l'histoire à la géopolitique
on voit bien que quand la liberté
politique va me liberté religieuse
pardon va mal la liberté des cultes va
mal en général le reste ne va pas très
bien c'est légal et en égard ont donc
c'est absolument essentiel et de façon
générale partir sur des critères
objectifs c'est-à-dire se dire non mais
la cij autorise les supermarchés dans
tel contexte par exemple un grand
supermarché avec 30 personnes à
l'intérieur
pourquoi une cathédrale encore plus
grande avec 30 personnes à laterrière
respectant d'excellentes conditions ne
seraient pas aussi susceptible d'ouvrir
je crois qu'il faut rester vraiment dans
l'objectif pour éviter que les français
cette sensation d'arbitraire pense aussi
que c'est pas juste le de dire que
c'était arbitraire parce que le premier
ministre on l'entendait hier il était
interrogé par les députés visés oui je
sais bien qu'il ya des magasins de
sauver souffert mais c'est pas pour
emmerder les gens c'est juste parce que
je veux qu'ils bougent le moins possible
donc moi il ya deux magasins ouverts et
moi jadriya le virus circule à une vraie
injustice dans cette histoire pour le
gouvernement de fait ils essayent de
faire quand même nettement tout ce qui
peut il a débloqué des fonds il continua
en débloquer pour essayer d'aider les
gens qui sont là aujourd'hui forte à la
peine alors évidemment il ya un problème
de lisibilité des aides les gens s'y
perdent et c'est donc là il ya quelque
chose à faire de ce côté là enfin ils
essayent de faire ce qu'il peut et de
toute façon il ne pourra pas faire ce
qu'il faut parce que cette pandémie pose
un problème à tous les états à tous les
gouvernements il n'y a pas de bonne
solution
en fait vous est pris entre le respect
effectivement de la vie biologique comme
olivier la contrainte économique
l'arbitrage économique et puis la
cohérence des mesures vous avez ces
trois piliers là qu'il faut articuler en
permanence c'est un fait impossible n'a
véritablement je pense que je ne
souhaite à personne
non mais vraiment n'ont en revanche rien
à quelque chose je pense qu'il faut
intégrer le paramètre du temps et en
effet en intégrant ce par m puisqu'on va
pas en être débarrassés tout de suite de
ce qu vide le gouvernement ne peut pas
se permettre d'atteindre déjà le point
de rupture
donc pour revenir à ce qu'on disait au
début c'est à dire que si ça monte à ce
point-ci fort là maintenant ça va être
très difficile de tenir sur la durée
puisque le vaccin
même si on peut tout petit mais c'est
pas pour demain tout de suite ça veut
dire aussi que du coup de l'autre côté
fo se permettre de lâcher du lest c'est
là où en fait on sait pas trop c'est à
dire qu'on se rend bien compte qu'il va
falloir assouplir qu'on va pas tenir sur
ce qu'est la mais de l'autre côté
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire à ce que
parce que ils ont aussi le gouvernement
les médecins qui leur disent tous les
jours on ne va pas pouvoir tenir enfin
j'veux dire il ya une autre réalité de
l'autre côté et genevois opa enfin
comment un gouvernement pourraient
laisser mourir les gens enfin soyons
soyons clair ça n'est pas tenable
d'où la prudence de gabarit avale tout à
l'heure c'est normal c'est un peu le cas
c'est donc là on parle moins
donc il faut bien qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire et ce qu'il faut former des passes
et qu'est ce qui manque c'est pas que
des lycées aussi des professionnels donc
il faudrait qu'ils nous expliquent aussi
ce qui se prépare de l'autre côté pour
essayer de tenir à long terme et dernier
petit point pour rebondir sur ce que
disait gabriel je pense aussi qu'il ya
quand même quelque chose dans ce débat
on entend beaucoup parler des petits
commerçants on entend moins parler des
indépendants de la culture on a on parle
de la culture avec les librairies mais
on parle pas forcément de la culture
sous l'aspect artistes enfin un peu
moins je trouve ce sont des gens qui
vont aussi être vraiment dans de très
grandes difficultés et ça renvoie un peu
ça me semble un peu étonnant de la part
d'un gouvernement
on a beaucoup parlé de gaulle ces
derniers temps de gaulle a quand même
restauré à regret le ministre lacunes
ministère de la culture
une idée qui avait été très abîmée par
les gouvernements comment dire
dictatoriaux des décennies précédentes
donc c'est quand même curieux qu'en
france on parle aussi peu de la culture
et la culture elle renvoie un autre
aspect de la santé telle qu'elle a été
définie par l oms qui effectivement pas
la santé biologiques comme michel
foucault lisez amenant les gouvernements
aujourd'hui moderne à faire de la
biopolitique en se centrant sur le corps
des citoyens
mais la santé psychique et là c'est vrai
que c'est un autre paramètre dont il yal
paramètres économiques de ces petits
commerçants mais il ya aussi la santé
psychique du français là aussi je pense
que c'est en train de se
2 comment dire de se dégrader à vitesse
grand v avant de venir j'entendais à la
radio
une étude qui montrait combien les gens
qui travaillent qui ont qui sont pas au
chômage partiel ont le moral absolument
sous la ligne de flottaison
donc je pense que là aussi c'est un
paramètre qui invita a lâché je vous en
y allant jusqu'à nos internautes que
c'est la question du jour
sur le figaro.fr faut-il commencer le
déconfinement dès le 27 novembre je ne
sais pas si on a déjà des chiffres et
des résultats à vous donner
oui eh bien c'est 68 % de réponses
favorables mais 31% de nom alors ce
n'est pas un sondage mais il ya quand
même 22 mille votants donc voilà c'est
un c'est un coup de sonde sur le moral
des troupes est effectivement
l'impatience grandit parlons maintenant
si vous le voulez bien deux
ce sujet qui est l'enseignement de
l'arabe à l'école vous savez que le
gouvernement prend un certain nombre
d'initiatives pour lutter contre ce
qu'il appelle les séparatistes c'est à
dire le développement du communautarisme
essentiellement le communautarisme de
certains musulmans et la question se
pose est-ce que l'enseignement
l'éducation nationale plutôt doit
prendre en charge l'enseignement de
l'arabe pour éviter que les
petits-enfants de cette culture là
prennent dans des mosquées avec toutes
les rives de tous les risques pardon de
dérives possibles ou au contraire est-ce
que ce n'est pas le travail de l'état
gérald darmanin à eric dupond moretti
les deux ministres qui sont en charge de
ce dossier sont interviewé ce matin dans
le figaro
alors ils sont d'accord ça vous
surprendra pas gérald darmanin nous
explique ainsi qu'il faut apprendre
l'arabe dans les écoles de la république
et pas dans les mosquées et eric
dupond-moretti renchéri en disant la
langue arabe n'est pas en elle-même
porteuse de séparatisme est ce aussi
votre point de vue gabriel cluzel pas du
tout ça ne va pas vous étonner
je crois qu'il faut savoir un peu
bénéficié de l'expérience des anciens et
on a toujours vu que l'unité d'un pays
passé
pars pars salles en août a laissé albert
camus qui disait ma patrie c'est la
langue française donc implicitement
envoyer ce signal là alors qu'il est
peut-être aussi guide de la com parce
qu'en réalité je ne sais pas ce que ça
va changer réellement puisque l'arabe et
déjà enseigné en tant que langue
étrangère dans tout un tas de deux
d'école je pense notamment le lycée
kléber à strasbourg
ils ont fait une filière justement
première langue arabe pour permettre aux
quartiers défavorisés d'être attirés
dans ce grand lycée tard donc c'est
quelque chose qui est déjà fait mais en
réalité ces données et pose de renforcer
nyala ils sont proposés le remplacer et
puis c'est donner un mauvais signal à
ceux justement qui travaillent sur ce
sur ce séparative d'ailleurs pourquoi
l'arabe on se demande pourquoi la vie de
tout un tas de communautés actuellement
qui sont dans notre dans notre pays
pourquoi pas le le wolof pourquoi pas le
pakistanais pourquoi pas le turc en
réalité qu'est ce que l'arabe c'est pas
l'arabe ne renvoie pas à l'origine de
ces enfants elle revoir renvoie à une
religion à l'islam puisque dans toutes
les mosquées en réalité qu'elle soit
pakistanaise égyptienne turcs eux on
parle arabe
donc on est en train de faire une unité
une espèce d'unités religieuse là où
précisément ceux se ses communautés un
peu c'est parait évident que l'islam
conquérants à avance à grands pas donc
c'est exact exactement
l'exemple typique de la mauvaise idée
leur pour réaliser faut prendre exemple
sur les anciens parce que et vous on
al'exemple finalement assez prégnant ici
de l'alsace l'alsace qui à chaque fois
qu'elle redevenait allemande ou
française
réapprenez l'allemand ou réapprenez le
français et on voyait bien que les
allemands et les français avaient
conscience à quel point c'était
constitutifs de du patriotisme de chacun
et je dirais leur ont à chaque fois
qu'on évoque ce sujet on a l'impression
que c'est une violence faite aux ce qui
arrive chez nous évidemment que non si
vous aviez étiez en suède
guillaume avec vos enfants vous n'exigez
riez pas et vous ne seriez pas étonné
que on ne s'implique pas en suède a
appelé la apprendre la langue française
à vos enfants ou le latin side aventure
vous considère ça comme la langue de la
religion catholique
donc c'est on voit bien qu'à cesser
c'est typiquement la fausse bonne idée
et on pourrait même dire que c'est
absolument ubuesque dans sachant que
cela rentre dans un programme de lutte
contre contre le séparatisme et dernier
point ce qui les fondamentalistes qui
souhaitent apprendre l'arabe à la
mosquée continuerons à le faire et très
probablement de mécréant le pôle e le
professeur qui aura été missionné par
par les infidèles pour reprendre le mot
des mots utilisés récemment à l'encontre
du présent de la république beaucoup de
choses à dire
ça va être un peu alors déjà il ya une
certaine hypocrisie dans la présentation
que vous faites de l'enseignement de
l'arabe
parce que certes ça existe mais c'est ça
représente 0,2 pour cent des élèves pour
quelle raison parce qu'en france
précisément l'enseignement de l'arabe il
est entouré d'une méfiance
incommensurable il n'y a pas de
professeur pour enseigner donc ce que
veut dire le gouvernement c'est
qu'effectivement au même titre que
d'autres langues
le néerlandais le chinois l'allemand et
j'en passe il n'y a pas de raison qui
n'est pas une offre digne de ce nom pour
les élèves qui veulent apprendre l'arabe
ça c'est le premier point
donc on parle pas de petites communautés
où elle offre les musulmans et qui parle
des gens qui parlent arabe y en a quand
même un peu plus les eaux alors les
france donc il ya quand même un certain
nombre de français qui parle arabe donc
qu'ils aient envie
non mais je veux dire ok en vidéo et
alors c'est pas parce qu'on apprend on
peut rester extra deuxième point c'est
pas parce qu'on est dans une autre
langue
enfin une autre langue que la sienne à
l'école que ont fait montre d'une
volonté séparatistes ou alors qu'on à
lutter le projet républicain alors là
vraiment cerner les problèmes à lanfains
entendez je vous avais parlé longuement
je vous réponds donc ça déjà je ne vois
pas je ne vois pas dans la démonstration
vous venez de faire précisément
l'argumentation qui pourrait nous amener
à penser que apprendre l'arabe à l'école
c'est favoriser l'islamisme et excusez
moi je ne vois pas le lien deuxième
point vous avez un 22 nanomètres
laissez moi deviner ce que vous avez
longuement parlé deuxième point en fait
en croyant lutter contre l'islamisme
il nous arrive vraiment très fréquemment
la même chose on rentre dans leur
logique les islamistes ils font de
l'arabe ne langue sacrée c'est à dire à
part en parlant de la langue arabe
de cette façon nous faisons exactement
la même chose nous en faisons une langue
à part
pourquoi dénier à la langue arabe la
dimension culturelle qu'on admet
parfaitement pour les autres langues
j'ai parlé du chesnois il faudrait vous
dire pourquoi mais on n'en veut briser
la question c'est quand même
parfaitement bien tourner un grand
islamologue promet d'arkoon heureusement
d'une certaine manière qu'il n'est plus
là aujourd'hui à ce qu'ils vont dire m
l'islam parce que ça met donc c'est pas
ma peau mais maintenant mais alors je
veux dire est ce que ça fait des gens
qui apprennent la langue arabe des
terroristes en puissance formé à le dire
d vous ne vivez pas sur la sur la lune
j'imagine bien donc vous avez bien vu
qu'on a un petit souci actuellement
voilà pas plus que moi j'en suis
convaincu vous avez vous voyez qu'on a
un souci actuellement avec l'intégration
d'un certain nombre de gens et il se
trouve que ce ne sont pas des danois et
des suédois donc c'est bien de lutter de
citer ces exemples-là mais en
l'occurrence ce n'est pas que de leurs
dépens de la non à bien non je ne suis
pas d'accord
non parce que pour faire des français
voient leur amende j'ai accueilli et je
la vis sans doute un exemple supprimé
purement rendez vous savez très bien que
que notre le rôle de la france n'est pas
d'apprendre l'arabe à des petits enfants
qui ont déjà du mal à londres à devenir
des français que c'est marc ailleurs
cette loi est censée lutter contre le
séparatisme et on vient nous dire qu
apprendre l'arabe permettrait de lutter
cont re super donc ce secret à wattrelos
oui on a un problème est que les chinois
les chinois on a déroulé on a un
problème avec les chinois actuellement
le séparatisme chinois non je ne crois
pas ils formeront n'y voyez là comme le
terreau le fondamentalisme chinois le
terrorisme chinois le séparatisme en
gorille en dix ans les élèves vont
apprendre l'arabe sont nommés annonce
que ans a décidé alors de vous dire le
le jugement que je porte c'est que j'ai
en effet il ya un certain nombre
d'enfants cédera issu d'un de ces pays
qui est qui ces deux pays du bassin
méditerranéen viau intéressante qui en
effet ont du mal à s'assimiler
donc c'est évident que pour les aider à
devenir des petits français
il faut leur apprendre le français
d'autant que ces enfants là ont du mal à
la plante valérie banane on le sait
s'est dit on lui et ça c'est non je
pense que ces gars là vous disent que
vous et vous refusez de leur apprendre
le français
un jour vous êtes
de me dire je m'en lave votre position
mais l'idée qu'il faille
on pourrait être con pour être qu'on
pourrait effectivement m m mettre le
paquet sur le français et quitte à ce
que ces jeunes enfants puissent
apprendre la langue arabe à la maison je
préfère je veux dire je préfère que
s'ils le veulent effectivement ils
fassent connaissance avec l'arabe d'airé
standard moteurs rolls plutôt qu'un
haram qu'on peut leur apprendre à côté
qu'il est l'arabe soi-disant littéraire
auquel ils vont vraiment rien comprendre
qui va être propice a effectivement
faire passer d un endoctrinement
islamistes parce que contrairement ce
que vous pensez je suis tout aussi
comment dire attaché à l'idée de lutter
contre le séparatisme et l'islamisme ça
n'a rien à voir mais je pense
qu'effectivement renouer éventuellement
avec ses origines linguistique
je ne vois pas en quoi c'est le rose à
la france devait faire renouer ces
engins qui ont déjà du mal à intégrer
dans un bruit encore permis d'assimiler
à la leur apprendre leur langue
d'origine
il ya tout un tas de gens qui apprennent
leur langue d'origine c'est tout à fait
respectable moi je suis tout à fait pour
que les gens gardent leurs racines et
c'est c'est tout à leur honneur mais ils
peuvent la prendre à la maison le rôle
de la france et d'apprendre le français
surtout quand on en est on est dans une
démarche d'union
c'est évidemment tomber sous le sens
gabriel compagnie c'était comme si on
les aurait que les lois bien qu un
signal je m'adresse je pense je ne sais
pas si c'est tout à fait perçu en haut
lieu pourtant il ya un certain nombre de
gens qui l'expliquent c'est que ce qui
pousse cet islam conquérant qui nous
plonge dans l'inquiétude actuellement en
disons le et bien sont dans un rapport
de force
donc je me demande quel regard ils
portent sur ce gouvernement qui pour
lutter contre le séparatisme joliment
pudique puis est en réalité pour lutter
contre le communautarisme et ce
communautarisme la voix cette suggestion
de faire apprendre l'art à moi je serai
eux
j'avoue que ça me ferait un peu rires je
je je ne vois pas très bien
c'est gentil de les aider à faire
l'union mais je la marsa je vois pas
très bien et moi là dessus parce que
merci d'être allé au bout de votre
désaccord puisqu'on voit qu'il n'y aura
pas de consensus sur ce sujet un dernier
mot clair puis après ça j'avais une
autre question à vous poser est vraiment
je vous attends j'attends qu'on me fasse
la preuve qu effectivement apprendre
l'arabe à l'école ça favorise le sida et
on voit bien que c'est là le fond de
votre désaccord il ya un autre projet
dans cette loi contre le séparatisme une
autre idée qui même lui elle entre dans
la loi alors que cette idée ce sujet
pardon de l'enseignement de l'arabe à
l'école ne sera pas dans le dans le dans
le projet de loi même si elle est dans
l'actualité et ce sujet c'est là
l'enseignement à la maison je sais pas
si vous avez écouté nos confrères
d'europe 1 ce matin mais il ya eu une
altercation va dire un débat assez vif
comme celui qu'on vient d'avoir entre
gérald darmanin le ministre de
l'intérieur et mathieu bélie arqués qui
est notre confrère d'europe 1 qui
présente la matinale et qui est aussi un
fervent défenseur de l'école à la maison
peut-être avez-vous lu la tribune qu'il
avait fait paraître dans le figaro il y
a quelques jours sur ce sujet alors là
je sais pas si vous allez être d'accord
ou non la suppression dès l'école à la
maison bonne ou mauvaise idée claire
chartier alors c'est un peu difficile
d'avoir une aussi vite
non mais d'après ce que j'ai ce que j'ai
lu des propos de 2010 de l'éducation
jean michel bancaire les enfants qui
poserait un problème
pour revenir au sujet du séparatisme en
tout cas d'une islamisation à qui sera
hissée la mise et représenterait une
pension quand même très congrue des
enfants scolarisés domicile donc bon
après c'est c'est extrêmement compliqué
de savoir il faudrait qu'il y ait des
contrôles en tous cas moi ce que je
pense parce que d'après ce que ce que je
me comprends aussi seront quand même
autorisé certains cas dire que tout
n'est pas interdit il ya dans les cas de
lorsque par exemple votre enfant a une
phobie scolaire effectivement ça se
comprend parfaitement que vous soyez
avec lui chez à la maison un moment il y
aurait 1 les raisons médicales et 2 le
cas très particulier des parents par
exemple des gens qui font le tour du
monde
des cas de ce type malheureusement
illimité on en a tous seraient non mais
on voit bien dans ces questions c'est
toujours la même c'est à dire que la
lutte contre eux aujourd'hui contre le
terrorisme et l'islamisme
nous sommes est notre conception de la
liberté à une réexamen en tout cas une
tension une polémique dont je crois que
là on exactement sur ce sur ce sujet là
a priori je serai en tout cas je pense
qu'il faut être vigilant sur cette
question dassa entièrement d'accord je
crois que véritablement c'est propice à
beaucoup beaucoup de d'endoctrinement
probablement vous n'êtes pas sûr non en
fait je pense qu'il faut approfondir le
sujet oui après il faut le préciser que
quand je parlais de ces deux cas le cas
médical est le cas des situations
spécifiques des parents c'était les
exceptions voulu a priori dans le dans
le projet pour maintenir l'école à la
maison qui sinon ne seraient plus
autorisées que vous pensez que c'est une
bonne idée
non je pense que c'est une mauvaise idée
d'interdire les cas la maison il ya tout
un tas de parents qui font très bien
l'école à la maison quelquefois donc
parce qu'ils sont dans des coins reculés
de campagne ce serait très compliqué
pour eux de faire des conduites où ils
n'ont pas trouvé l'école de leur choix
et il est normal et pour le moment il ya
eu un contrôle tout à fait bien fait je
crois d'éducation ça jamais posé de
problème que les parents et gardent
cette liberté d'enseignement moi ça me
choque parce que c'est encore une
liberté que l'on vient nous enlever
c'est encore l'état qui vient s'immiscer
dans la famille moi ce qui m'agace un
petit peu c'est que alors c'est parti de
la loi du séparatisme
une fois sur le séparatisme une fois de
plus donc on découvre que il y aura un
certain nombre de problèmes dont pour le
moment je ne crois pas que par exemple
dans le cadre du terrorisme un enfant
soit issu de ces familles là mais je
peux me tromper
on a donc de defacto on va retirer les
libertés de tout le monde et c'est un
peu ça depuis le début depuis qu'on a
des problèmes avec cet islam qui avance
que j'ai encore une fois conquérant
c'est à dire l on a fait une loi sur les
signes religieux extérieur alors par
exemple tous et tous les gens qui
portait une petite médaille n'est toile
de david ou une main de fatma discrète
maintenant le porte plus à l'école parce
que on a décidé que c'était dans le
cadre de l'ensemble des signes religieux
en réalité avec un problème religieux
pas les autres mais c'est les autres qui
ont été punis pour autant on n'a rien
réglé sur l'histoire du voile je vous
rassure
pareil je vois les prix
d'origine tenté c'est une actualité
récente j'entendais des journalistes
dire ah oui mais c'était peut-être des
prières de rue là les chapelets et
récité devant le parvis par référence à
ces prières qui bloque pour réclamer par
an pour réclamer des lieux religieux
mais les prières de rue ça existe depuis
1500 ans il ya eu des processions va pas
atteindre 101 dérogation tout ce que
vous voulez des fêtes du 100e d'une fête
dieu on va pas un tendre et interdire le
pèlerinage de saint jacques de
compostelle
parce qu'actuellement il ya des gens qui
se mettent dans la rue parce qu'il
réclame une bosse qui bloque le mag la
circulation
là ça me fait le même effet bien si ça
concerne un certain nombre de familles
qu'on règle ce problème avec ces
familles là mais qu'on punisse pas de
façon générale parce qu'on n'a pas envie
de nommer les abbés d'appeler un chat un
chat et de nommer les choses par leur
nom et de voir la peau mulele la
population qui pose souci de doter cette
liberté à l'ensemble de la population et
une fois plus ça ne réglera rien merci
un dernier mois là dessus que ça m'amuse
et un peu parce que là pour le coup le
lien avec le séparatisme l'islamisation
et les plus évidents pour l'enseignement
de la langue arabe
donc vous réserve la même me faisait
sourire voilà peut-être que l'heure est
grave et plus spécifiquement la langue
d'une religion alors que l'école à la
maison
quel est le lien avec tombola évident
lorsque vous avez la maison que vous
êtes vous-même endoctrinés c'est plus
simple
merci beaucoup merci à toutes les deux
et râler je le disais au bout de vos
convictions sur ce plateau c'était
passionnant merci à tous bon soir et à
demain pour un nouveau point de vue
[Musique]